Master Christian Tissier.
This is to certify that Christian Tissier
is awarded the 8th Dan in Aikido.
Made on the 10th of January 2016,
Aikido Doshu Ueshiba Moriteru.
What does this 8th Dan mean to you?
8th, Dan is a great honor
I am delighted.
It's the product of a very long journey
since it represents more than 55 years of Aikido,
but at same time, it's the beginning of a new responsibility,
for myself, for my students.
but also for what I represent with respect to the Aikikai.
What I want to add is...
the 8th Dan is the same grade as that of the most prestigious masters,
but on my side, I still have the soul of a kid, and that feels strange.
I still feel like a kid of Aikido
so I take this with a lot of humility
and a lot of gratefulness towards Doshu
who on the one hand may be giving the 8th Dan to a non-Japanese for the first time,
and on the other hand,
this 8th Dan coincides with that of Miyamoto Shihan
who received his 7th Dan at same time as me in 1998.
There has been no national preference
and I find this very good and quite valorizing for me.
Doshu, Dojo-cho, Tada Sensei, all the Sensei, thank you very much.
I entered Hombu Dojo 47 years ago
and since that time, I have always been faithful to the Ueshiba family.
From today, and tomorrow, I will continue to give my very best for Aikido.
Thank you very much.
What does it represent for the people who avail themselves of your "line"?
There is no Tissier "line" in terms of an organization.
The fact is that I am a product of the Aikikai.
This 8th Dan proves that I am totally in the line of the Aikikai.
I didn't want to create groups in around the world such as the Birankai or that of Yamda Sensei.
A number of people who claim to follow my teaching
decided to call that the "Tissier line"
That's how it started, and it doesn't originate from me.